all right point number two
and this is going to be a tough one for
some of the ladies to swallow and i
think some of you guys might already
understand this concept but some of you
really don't understand the significance
of number two
and it's that women have a overly
entitled sense of self-worth today
that is not that is nowhere near aligned
with their true sexual marketplace value
i'll give you a very good example of
this um from time to time i
have consults book with women sometimes
they send me
uh requests to do videos on something
that they're stuck on
and i had this one the other day where
she was late 30s
she made quite good money she made about
30 plus thousand dollars a month
at the job that she was doing she had
done well for herself
she figured out she cracked the code on
the company of one working for herself
broadcasting information and making some
money at it and again she'd done quite
well
but here's the catch uh at her late 30s
almost at 40 in fact she had two
children
one of which she had earlier this year
so she's basically
got a baby and the other one looks
somewhere around the age of um
let's just say under the age of four um
and harass to me was
i want to find a guy and i need your
help uh
i'm single i'm a single mom here's my
story i make a lot of money
but i want an alpha male that makes more
money than me
and is smarter than me now this is not
something that's particularly new
um you'd think that this is the first
time this had popped up or i've never
heard this before but
this is in fact quite common uh she had
no
accurate um idea of what her value was
on the suction marketplace
um she was a pretty woman in her younger
years right
i know all these things because she
linked her social feed for me to take a
look at who she was
she was a pretty woman in her younger
years but after
two kids a marriage who knows what else
led up to it
her looks have deteriorated
significantly
but she was at the point where she felt
entitled with a baby in tow and a small
child divorced her husband left her by
the way because he got involved with
another woman
but she felt entitled for a higher value
guy
than the one that had left her for
another woman with kids in tow
and expecting him to make more money
than her
and also be an alpha male and i'll be
honest with you
there is no man out there around her age
bracket because it's
really around that age bracket that
she's that that she's really going to
have any opportunities
that would be you know willing to
take on the burden of another man's
children
take on the burden of uh dealing with
all the drama that's tied around that
for a woman that is nowhere near the
peak of her sexual marketplace value
women peak around 23
22-23 after that they're on the decline
men on the other hand
have um the opportunity to peak
much much later on in their life and
when they do
um it's actually it's actually good for
men because
men can peak later in their life let's
say in their late 30s or so maybe even
closer to 40 depending on
how well it is that they take care of
themselves but
there's a big discrepancy and women's
self um
uh belief you know their entitlement of
their sexual marketplace value is much
much higher and it's and it's simply
because
they've had so much free attention their
entire life
mostly by thirsty betas and men that
just kind of just throw it at them
continuously
they get it off social media you know
this woman again you know she wrote
she wrote off a company of one business
model working for herself making 30 plus
thousand dollars a month
obviously had a good following obviously
had the attention
and adoration of a lot of people i would
imagine her audience seemed to be
primarily female because of the stuff
that she was promoting and selling
but there's no guy in his right mind
that would choose that
an alpha male let's say that makes over
thirty one thousand dollars a month
because that that's one of her demands
we know that women are hypergamous so
they always want
better than what they are uh women only
date and marry up
on the socio-economic scale um for the
most part
on a short term basis if it's alpha c
they just want to have a
one night stand of fling there's there's
nothing that's going to stop them from
uh spending the night with some guy that
was just in jail if he's alpha enough
but on a long term basis again
hypergamy says they only date and marry
up so you have to understand as a guy on
the sexual marketplace today
women have an overly entitled sense of
self-worth
um and have this belief that they're
worth significantly more
than what their true marketplace value
is uh women struggle with that they have
a very very hard time accepting that at
some point
they may smack into a wall and realize
oh wow that was
you know that was an eye opener there's
usually some moment where they realize
i need to lower my expectations i need
to have a more realistic standard
of my worth out there because it doesn't
matter how much money women make
they don't share it with men men are
dumb we share our pot of gold with women
women don't share their pot of gold with
with men
on a long term basis they have the
expectation again you know as i
described with this woman's
request that they connect with somebody
that is better off
and and of course you know ticks off all
these boxes is so alpha
um many of the expectations that you
know women seem to have it's like
must be funny must be sweet must be
loving must be kind must
accept you know my children as her own
must be alpha must be competent must
know how to change a tire must know how
to do
dude and it's like they have this
checklist of 250 items
that they expect you to meet for you to
have the privilege
of dating a late 30s woman
with children in tow one baby and
the dude that she was with left her i
told her straight up
uh you need to one either lower your
expectations of what you're looking for
or two take the father of your kids back
because one it's better for your kids
and two
you're not going to do much better i saw
the pictures of the guy in the feet
but that's the cold hard truth like
that's the cold harsh reality
that women struggle to accept men need
to understand it
women are unlikely to want to accept it
at some point but again this is number
two guys this is a reality
you